So today is John, Jack Lew. So, uh,
I mean one of the most fascinating people,
uh,
in terms of his life and his ideas
and the way how he reasons he is a
provocative right approval culture,
uh,
and uh,
an extra ordinary genius
in more than a rom base,
um,
that our fuel people who buy this agrees
so strongly than in Manny proposition
or zone Jockers so that,
that are for people.
Few people who turn my mind off up
was to own so much that John Shock.
So who was this character?
And let me just give you
a very brief overview.
He was worn in Geneva,
which was a city state at that time,
uh,
ruled by Calvin. Uh, for awhile.
Like Calvin is strong clue, uh, reveal.
Talking about this around it comes to
Max Labor and the Protestant ethic.
Calvin Rule Geneva with an iron hands.
That's right.
He was born,
his father was Isaac crucial.
He was a watchmaker and the Calvinist,
uh,
well he did run into some trouble.
I don't know exactly what the trouble was.
I think he was in that.
So he jumped the boat and
vent to Istanbul disappeared.
We don't know much about
him beyond that. So, uh,
at the very early age of them,
it was a kind of orphan.
Then in 17,
28,
he moved to France and
there was a wonderful lady,
uh,
about 10 years,
his senior Mrs warrants
was running at home.
Um, then are actually more seats
over here, you know, and uh,
that are, um, uh,
VIP seats right here. So
you can come in here, right?
This is specific are these are for
you that are four seats here, right?
And that our fifth and six over
there, don't be embarrassed, right?
You still can see the
power points from here.
It's not like in the bad movie
that when you sit in the front row,
you don't see anything of these.
So he mad.
Mrs Warren's,
who was
a Roman Catholic and her
mission was to Cornell Vert,
right? These, uh, um,
Calvin is through the wrapper fate,
Roman Catholicism and two
young boys into her home,
but through nose it looks like she had
more interest in people rather than
religion. So, uh, um,
he arrived 28,
two Anansi,
right? Age of 16. Good Looking,
nice guy.
Uh,
modern warrants is still a young little
lady here. You can see, you know,
uh,
um,
I know Warren's as Ron's
rock rise meeting in 17,
28. That is romantic stuff, right?
Uh, uh, well, uh,
you know, and here another
picture, you know, ah,
ah, I don't blame drawn
shock, right at the age of 16,
a tool called birth to Roman Catholicism,
right from the coal to Calvinist
religion and me and vile,
uh, being got Beth through
a mind tick, right? Well,
as long as Jack is one
of those few people, uh,
who ruled Akon fashion,
very funny book,
he has a sense of self identity
and self criticism rather.
This is genuine. Or he thought this
will be the way how to sell their book.
Hard to tell,
but it's worth reading.
It actually was published posts to,
and he said,
madam [inaudible] arms
shaped his character.
Undoubtedly she did.
Um,
and this affair have
here, who knows, Marty,
it looks like it was an affair.
Fascinated people.
Uh, later on. Um, uh,
I think I already flagged his joke in
the introductory lecture is Rhonda for
French writer,
some diarrhea and he's superb novel La
little rules along the wire was inspired
by these interests in your fear,
right?
A 16 year old boy and
mth age year old woman.
And in fact,
a story off Julianne
Shore Rather Means Jones,
Jacques Rousseau and Marge.
I'm there and I own the right,
um,
as three La the core of the story.
So if you have not read little's Alot,
why this is a must for
an ivy league graduate,
you'll do until I'm to
get that degree from Yale,
not having rat Staun died.
I had a rule,
Sha Alon,
the why it's of course in English then,
but you know, enough is enough, uh,
in 40 to seven or a year of slasher rules
saw has a now bigger aims and he moves
to pays and he becomes the secretary of
[inaudible] who was a French ambassador
to Vantis and that out a lot
of Nice things about, uh,
interesting things about little sore,
but he was not an easy,
um, and not, not an easy guy.
And somehow he all,
there's run into trouble.
So he run into trouble in the vanish and
in order to avoid avast and probable,
I don't know exactly what he did,
probably something shot in,
not quite correct.
He had to jump and leave vanish
and corn do more on tech.
Google,
uh,
he most of payers and he knows
how to find good friends.
He also will know how to make
Greek enemies from his gut fence.
So he meets a digital and if he already
know these wrong and we know already all
sequel p d and the French
and light demand. Um,
and uh,
he was asked to write an article on
the music from the [inaudible] the,
and this is Deidre. Um, okay.
And then he needs,
ted is a lot of sure.
He was saying, you know,
tell and tear is lava. Sure.
It was a need in these hotel and a long
lasting relationship develops between
the two, which, well, I already told you,
don't throw worry if you don't
marry instantly. He was not mad.
It instantly either.
Uh,
if took him some time to decide that,
that these date,
uh,
should act surely column in
eight in our legal marriage,
um, she became a companion
for all of his life. Uh,
uh,
well I would not bet my life that
she was for that essence of life,
the only women in his life,
but suits only as she lost his Bandana.
I don't know about her.
They married in [inaudible] 68
so you can see it took some time,
uh, for Russo to say,
thou this is something,
it should end up in a manage
and here is a cave yellow here.
You can't see that, right?
That as Jacques, uh,
well I hope you don't mind.
I'll show you these pictures.
They don't tell all that much.
John Shock,
as I said,
was an extra ordinary genius
is not only a philosopher,
not only as social scientist,
not only a scientist,
he was writing on science as well.
He was an artist and their,
you know,
anybody can write a novel,
right?
I am sure half of this class considered
at one point in your life that you will
write poetry or uveal Rato model.
Right? That's easy. You're, you,
you sit down and you write a
novel. My life is a novel, right?
Most people say that Matt Jones,
Rock Road, art, Farrah,
probably a few of you considered right.
And after that Nice kills,
right?
And he did wrong. Lou, the event, if lash,
I own a CD,
it's Alonda wonderful.
Okoro he's a great composer, right? Um,
well that's quite unusual.
And to make it even more interesting,
he was in an intensive Beatty was all
of us an intense debate with everybody,
but he was an intense
debates with Ron Hall.
And those are few are
level familiar with music.
You know,
Ron Moore,
Ron Moore was the Gri test French composer
of the 18th century and they had a
big debate because,
and rules so believed
in the Italian Aaker,
right? Um, he,
he believed that the melody should have
a precedence over Harmoni and raw mall.
Um,
one volunteer to create
a French upper and Vic,
you know, um, um, mellowed.
These not so important.
And in fact, uh, the
morning is morning put on.
It was a revolutionary break. Um, uh,
Ron Moore, the sea, you know,
creates a new space for the new music.
In some ways.
He beginning to Dave,
the vague what we eventually,
we all know as modern music
and extra ordinary composer.
Well,
I Rousseau believed in bear country.
True [inaudible]. I know,
of course they're not,
it was no Pavarotti at that time. They,
but you know what Bel Canto is of Amaria,
right? You create our cry,
you can sing it, right?
That's what he really believed in.
And unlike a Rameau who
was much more analytical,
right,
and emphasize Harmoni inch and assisting
the person whom I think is the greatest
composer of Ooh,
history of Wolfgang Amadeus,
Mozart loved
and he wrote an opera
but can be very rarely,
same scene who quetsion or you can catch
it in the metropole in not done upper
of arts once in a decade.
Bastianich and Bhasin niche
actually inspired by the Devin.
Go on amazon.com you can buy Rommel,
you can buy a Bostonian and
Bostonian and you can buy led event
and you can see the differences.
And of course, publishes
a novel. It does, uh,
Vishy Ha Julie and uh,
or the new hair loss,
which at that time was
an influential novel.
I don't think too many people
read it today. Now this is Rambo
and he is Rameau for shadow and
modern music Gluck in particular,
uh, uh, follows, uh, from
Rommel. In fact, you know,
more sad there'll be
changing in his lifetime. Um,
Vivia of talk of how,
you know,
just I thought if that is a
musician you can read other.
Yeah. Um, interestingly,
you know, more, uh,
did not stick quite to the
Italian upper over his life.
Um, uh, you, um, um,
probably her Saba flirter,
the magic flute is a first,
sure.
Oppor Ahh,
you earlier mortality is very much
Italian opera lace shirt in life.
More sad prior to create German opera,
which has some theme you allowed if these,
the French music,
not quite thousands is more romantic.
Okay.
He is also a philosopher,
scientist, political theorist.
I will also will say sociologist
and Bali think got a scientist.
The first piece of work is
actually science or art. Um,
and the study of society.
Uh,
then in 1755,
he writes some very interesting work.
If you have spare time, read it.
This course on the origin of inequality.
Uh,
again, very provocative
worker in some ways. Uh,
that is some sort of hop
Sian idea behind that is sad.
Well,
it starts with love,
but if you are really in love now,
um, you'll tend to be jealous, right?
If you are deeply in love,
passionately in love,
then you don't lie that the person
who is the object of your love May,
however,
all log in somebody else,
then you are jealous.
And the idea is this is the origins
of your neck quality, right?
We are jealous.
All right,
there is a long pressure's good
to put it with hops, right?
The old design.
And if somebody else is ours is that
well and it has a shot at it to get it,
then we become jealous,
right? We want to grab it,
move on to monopolize it.
So this is the source of inequality,
right? Sort of sink idea. All right.
Uh,
have you ever experienced that?
Did you have occasionally a level sense
of jealousy in you and thinking no,
these other ones should
not have the one I do have.
I think you probably did.
I did.
Okay.
And then comes the big here.
62,
he publishes two major books in one year.
Two big scandals,
social contract and Emile and Ivo
draw to social contract today.
And email social contract is really a
culmination of the contract area man hops
lock Andrew was so bit some extra
ordinary important innovations.
All right. Um, as we have seen,
uh, right, uh, in the first contract,
Cesarean harps had a somewhat
limited idea of social contract.
Probably realistic.
Uh,
but not what you necesarrily life.
He said the social contract is not
something what you conclude the video
authority, right? Social contract.
What you answered by
fear and social contract,
which was done previously before you run
that to have a new contract is binding
on you, right? Law Dan,
to see that consortium contract
as sort of between the individual.
Right. And the Common Val's, uh,
this is a nice idea,
right?
That you are bind by a
contract you signed. Wow.
You know,
um,
those are you at least two were
born in these United States.
Never signed a contract to
accept the constitution.
I am a naturalized citizen.
You can say I signed a contract,
I had to swear allegiance to the United
States at that time I was supposed to
read the constitution.
I have not read it from cover to cover.
But anyway, I signed the contracts,
some VOD on scene, you know,
suspecting what the contract is signing.
But most of you rad worn in this state,
never signed the contract. Right?
It's still binding on you,
right.
Unless you decide to abandon the u s
citizenship and become a citizen of North
Korea. Right. Then you are buying
by the social contract. So that,
that is, you know, the difference
between um, um, uh, uh,
harps and Lark as we discussed now
who saw as reviewers see s new,
new, new interesting element
is that, well it's not white.
The individual was,
and he introduces the
notion of general there.
There is a general Ville
which is well above, uh,
the individuals extremely
important idea has a degree of um,
insights and realism.
It's also a very dangerous idea.
Totalitarian regimes very often advocated
General Ville that you and re Ivf
Croak, uh, um,
John Jack for you when he's sad that
individuals have to be forced to be free.
That follows from the idea
of General Vale. Well,
he is a complex thinker,
liberal in Ronaghan,
that contact area and on the other,
the other hand and paves the road to
totalitarianism that he was loved by many
liberals and he was loved by
many totalitarians like God,
Mark Sloughed,
him and like Vladimir Ilyich.
Lenin loved him because of the
genital about Durkheim loft him too.
And he was a little bit off. So, uh,
that is Emil Ivy was talking about this
I already mentioned and Yvonne or fewer
that are probably a few people
who will end up in education.
You have to read this book cover to
cover that is no modern education theory.
The south,
the book in meal,
this is the foundation of
modern education or teary.
Okay.
He has a big impact,
a big impact on the American
constitution and the French Revolution.
He one of the bass breaker or,
or on on the French revolution,
he was also the first who
advocated pop, Suva, serenity,
um, um, uh, the abolishment of the Turd,
the state and creating warm
puppy elected body, right,
strong conflict.
It Montesquieu who want that to
have right to chain barriers.
Uh, one for the aristocracy
and one for the people.
A rooster wanted to have one
universal suffrage except for the man.
He was a male chauvinist pig in one way.
Well,
and as Vivia see the idea of gender veal
over picked up by the radicals of the
financial evolution.
Uh,
the Jacobins and Vos speaked up
by later communists of video,
Skype would be Atlanta in his store.
A malaise.
No,
the genital Ville and French
radicalism a led to bloodshed,
uh,
Robespierre the major disciple,
I'm believe her of gender,
all veal.
His hats for us also chopped
off so much about it.
Now, uh, Rousseau did not
live the French revolution.
His ideas there then that he had to
move in 62 in exile because both books
created an outrage,
particularly by the church,
first event to back to Geneva.
But figure it out.
It doesn't [inaudible] Ronnie longer.
So David Hume,
the conservative philosopher who admired
is very invited him to come to England.
And like with everybody
else who was his friends,
right?
He had a fall out of your day.
If it was really a difficulty guy,
right?
Uh,
this is David Hume,
and therefore he left England
and he return to France,
uh,
lived for a long time on the [inaudible]
named to make sure it doesn't get into
trouble flying all the 68 he married
[inaudible] ivo talking about this a meal.
They have several children and the
greatest educational theories to tells you
how to raise children.
He put all of his children an orphanage.
She was a real bastard, right? Do that.
Um, and then he was writing
his confessions, um,
which was published,
a boss almost Lee,
and he died in [inaudible] 78,
uh,
July the second.
So this is the orchard maybe
he will be discussing today.
And vivio be also discussing,
uh,
choose today
and I hope I have enough time,
uh,
via TV and
I get home,
I'd before the Leibow comms so I
can put this on the intern match.
So you can read the songs.
The ensurer match.
Uh,
this is fried the social contract.
Yes.
So Shaw contract 1782
and I don't know why,
but I like your show.
You the first additions,
uh,
doesn't take me too much time
to find it on the intranet.
Whatso occasionally does.
Okay.
So what is the social contract
is all about a book one,
uh, as a, a description.
How you move from natural right from
the state of nature to politic or,
um,
uh,
the second book is who is
the Silver Silverman and how
does silver and should be
constructed? Created. This
is an issue which, uh,
law did not pay much
attention to. Right. Um,
um, um, reveal, see, you know,
Rousseau himself likes elected,
uh,
selected aristocracy about,
he beginning to think about universal
suffrage and proper constitution of the
silver. And then he has a
big section on government.
Um, uh, a section on ancient
Roman CVO religion Ivy.
We'll talk now.
I don't have much time.
I have your try to talk
about cvs Allergan as well.
So what about other major themes?
One question is what is legitimate rule?
And he said rude is only
legitimate when it is, uh, uh, uh,
at, I have that consent. Bart.
He said Justice has to be the Lou
Tiede because genital Ville has to,
could have there I will have to talk
a little about justice being diluted.
The problem is that is
no universal justice.
What you can arrive at from the
individual veil that is a General Ville,
right?
And the conception of the comment and
gloves and the individual that the
individual is done justice to,
it has to be diluting.
It has to be restricted by the demands
of the collective Ville of the collective
good.
Now this is a provocative statement.
It certainly has a kernel of tools.
It's also very dangerous argument
because it opens up the rule for a
totalitarian state which will tell you,
oh,
you think this is your interest,
but you think is your interest is not
really your interest me the server and
knows what is in your restaurants and
ivy or force you to be Free Ivy or force
you to understand, right?
What is in your interest.
That is a bit of a tricky
argument, right? It had,
has been abused in history.
That's what the notion diluted refers to.
Now perhaps your he advocates for popular
serenity and the need for convention.
Um,
uh,
well the argument is that individual
will express only individual interest and
therefore the general deal is not the
veal of simply the sum total of Indivi
individual veils.
He is a metal door,
logical collectivist, right? Uh, uh,
as I already pointed out and
then it comes to the law giver,
uh,
it is the law giver who is actually can
inspire what he goes are more pro per.
You need a law giver.
He sees himself as a law giver who act
surely will be able to tell you why your
selfishness is no good by
the law of your country.
Younger community is the
right thing to go. Okay.
And the good government means a pop
jewelry elected legislature and the
executive is still by an aristocracy,
uh,
by a device man.
That's what he really means by
aristocracy and intellectual aristocracy.
Who is elected? Well, I may
have some bodies notion, right?
That people in government should be smart,
right?
And we have a bit of
concern. Uh, you know,
in the past there were some
presidents in the United States,
some people in the United States
through the are not all death smart,
right? I don't want to name names,
but you can think, probably have some,
right. Uh, who buys?
Some people thought they are a
little on the dumb side, right?
And they did not earn
real much respect right.
By those two things, they are
not smart anyway. That's it.
So legitimate through a,
they all legitimate rule cannot be amazed
or natural title lot aristocracy has
to be, um, uh, authorized by consent.
Um, well, I leave the family issue.
That's a family he said is
the only natural society.
Um, uh, Bart,
he said even the family does
not come simply from nature.
That is a social contract in
the family. And in fact, you,
when you, when you grew
up, um, uh, you know,
when you are not as smart shot anymore,
then you will realize how much
of a contract it is eventually.
I mean,
I hope that is nobody in this room,
but I suspect that I probably a very
few who at one point thought enough was
enough.
You know,
my mother and father is really a pain and
therefore I don't want to do much with
them. Need to break the contract. Right.
It does happen to some people
in their life as a father,
I hope it will never
happen, but on, fortunately,
it occasionally does.
A Brown people are teenagers.
That's when you beginning to think
about the natural right of the family,
right as a contract, right?
And you're beginning to answer,
or some people begin to
answer some kind offer, uh,
your relationship in the parents and try
to corner worth the natural dependence
on parents on a contractual relationship.
Right?
Uh,
saying,
what do you mean I have to be back
home by 11:30 AM you remember that?
I remember that. And try
to negotiate the towel. Oh,
not 11.
[inaudible] a am right.
I am already 16 or 17,
you know,
um, that span, you walk on
the birthing national. Right?
Okay.
Uh,
now that is a transition from state of
nature to the nature of civil society.
All right. Uh, uh,
uh,
eh,
that is the transition from the state
of nature to cvs or is NASA shut?
It is just a remarkable change right now
you substitute justice for ends thing.
Uh, I've contact, um, avid more reality,
which was lacking previously
in the state of nature.
MMM.
And in CVS society,
you know,
we deprive ourselves from
some of the advantages,
but we enjoy in the state of nature.
Nevertheless,
this is a great progress.
What has to be taken on.
If you see this also in Emea,
uh, now, uh,
the second theme is about the
question of the looted justice.
And he said, you know, at
the order add to admit,
justice among us has to be
diluted and diluted means,
you know,
uh,
our individual sense of justice has to
be overruled by the general veal and a
silver sedan, uh, needs
snow guarantor, uh,
and the individuals will
have to be rash constraint,
our device,
the R and [inaudible].
MMM.
And here, um, uh,
here is the argument why the individual
of you'll have to cross strange
individuals cannot adjust,
follow the south in showed us because
the genital veal have to prevail.
The common good has to overrule the
selfish individual interests and very
different type of argument.
But from the British liberals,
uh,
then he are used for popular sue
vanity and he's the first to do so.
Um, and this is his single
most important, uh, uh,
a contribution right at this has to be
based on a convention and the convention
has to be arrived at by
the rule of the majority.
Um, uh, there must be an
assembly of people, right?
And,
and this is also a very radical,
controversial argument that
the must pull the resources.
It is almost a communist idea of having
common property of major resources,
very problematic argument.
Uh,
and he also makes this interesting claim
that in the state of nature be are the,
are not equal.
That's a very different view from hops,
but we are being made equal by convention.
What we, uh, uh, uh, do with each other.
And the problem is this is really does
it lead to totalitarianism is also
advocating for public possessions
as a superior form of procession,
uh,
stage procession over a resources.
Very problematic argument.
Again,
paves the foundation drove was
Marxism and communists ideologies.
Um, and uh, well, uh,
many of the, you know,
all the citations VOB on the intranet
so you can read it much more carefully.
Then you can do it down.
Then we arrive at the idea of
the genital veal individual.
This is something you believe in Adam
Smith's or you believe in the law.
You will be very disturbed,
individual,
expressed only private interest.
So there must be a public interest
and the genital Ville is sort of a,
it's unclear where it is coming from,
but it is certainly coming over and above.
Uh,
the individuals. And this is
the, uh, the general veal,
which is represented with
what we call the common of,
right.
The federal authority.
The federal interest
expresses the genital veal.
It is not the veal of all is the bill,
which the interest of everybody
rather than the view of everybody.
Um, as I said, you know,
that is an element of true
stewards in discussion sections.
Vivio can talk about this.
The class will be divided better.
This is acceptable or not.
But those of you who believe
in methodological collectivism,
we'll have to take very seriously
the idea of General Ville.
And now comes the question
of the law givers.
And this is a very important argument.
Well,
viaud only free event of the obey the law,
right?
The freedom is a under south impulse law.
Uh, they, uh, hey girls
said that, uh, freedom,
uh, is, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
you are free.
Then you are recognized necessity.
And therefore a UVL have to go by
the law and this field and inspire,
uh, proper, uh,
the love of the country that,
uh, that are more the swap,
which is self love. He makes
this distinction. Yeah.
I am afraid I've, you'll have to
come back to this, uh, um, uh,
uh, cues today. I've, you'll
have to leave it now. Um, uh,
the distinction between Amore proper
and Amore the SWOT is a very important
distinction. And I have to
elaborate on this, uh, um,
Tuesdays. So I will come back, uh, to, uh,
to a social contract
before we go on to Mel.